hello everyone and welcome to the
highlight show of clashes international
my name is Santa Barbara Hammond and I'm
going to take you to the key moments of
day 5 which was also day 1 of the
semi-finals so we had two really
exciting matches Magnus Carlsen versus
Levon Aronian and Fabiano Khurana vs.
West Lisa so if you watch the first
edition of class chest and you know that
Wesley so defeated Fabiano Khurana to
win the tournament so both players have
a lot of experience and they're meeting
again in the same format for the second
time and of course Magnus versus LeBron
is a matchup that players and chess fans
always look forward to because they
yield such exciting results and games
so the to match is actually mirrored
each other and they had the same exact
result in every round which was unusual
but the results only tell half of the
story and the games were very unique and
had very many ups and downs so let's
jump right into it right into the
actions let's check out what happened
today so let's start with our match
between Magnus Carlsen and Levon Aronian
the game one started off really well for
level he was with the black pieces but
at some point things went terribly wrong
for him let's go to move 34 so as we can
see black is doing quite well with the
rooks on the second rank and in Magnus
plays rook G 4 and Livan grabs a pawn
which is already dangerous and after
Ricky 4 with seconds on his clock you
could see on camera he becomes became
very nervous he already realized that
he's blonde and he pondered something as
Quinn have 5 runs into rook F 4 with
maid coming and it's not clear where to
put the Queen and then he blundered
again queen h5 he takes the pawn but now
rook e6 and it's impossible to stop this
checkmate without giving up a lot of
material so Queen g7 would be the only
move so he resigned and give up the
Queen but of course there is no reason
for him to continue playing this so this
was a very unfortunate start for him
which could have been a win for him so
beating Magnus with the black pieces in
the first game could have really changed
the flow of the match but
it didn't happen so in this game Mac has
played the aloe kind with the black
pieces it's an opening we don't see very
often at the top level and it's also an
opening that doesn't have a great
reputation but Magnus tries it anyways
so let's jump to move 18
so the way Levin played this opening he
took quite a bit of quite a few
liberties of course black as this decide
this expand weakness but in the long
term but in the short term it does have
a king in the center so Bishop b2
so you really should have played 93 here
and black with the knight and now it
runs into some trouble so now the King
is in the center 55 opening the center
one of the principles of chess when your
opponent's king is in the center you
want to open the center to attack the
King so 9527 and simply wins a piece so
LaVon tries to find some resources in
the position but they're not quite there
so we reach an endgame so let's make the
next few moves and see how the game
ended so this is just a matter of
technique Magnus is simply up a piece on
the game does not last very long little
unfortunate but the game was already
over so this gives Magnus Carlsen a
2-point weight which is of course very
comfortable so let's take a look at the
next two game to the next two games
ended in a drop and there's always a key
thing to pay attention to when we have
this kind of Bishop endgame so when your
opponent has a passed pawn of course you
have to tend to it but then if it's a
corner pawn we have to pay attention to
the color of the bishop because it's a
dark square bishop and a it is a light
square we know that endgame is going to
end in a draw so let's take a look at
what happened so he look at the
placement of the night so a few more
moves so there's not much for me to say
just to take you to the end of the game
just to show you how this game ended so
he gives up his Knight and goes after
the pun
and let's move on to Game four
so let's jump to to this moment in the
game where I'm 11 once again had a good
position but missed a big opportunity
playing Queen after instead you should
have played Bishop F to the knight has
to go back and brought this Bishop here
and just simply taken upon unfortunately
plays Queen f2 and the game goes on for
a very long time let's jump to the end
of the game let's go to move 44 and
let's take a look at what happened so
lemon knows he tries to repeat the
position with magnus declines but there
isn't much to do for black here so you
gives up the route for a pretty funny
looking for petrol so the normal scoring
portion of the match ended and now enter
the clutch portion where each wing is
worth two points
unfortunately this part also did not go
well for Levin he lost the first game
which gave his opponent a four point
lead and actually this could have this
match could have gone way worse for him
so in a way at some point the bleeding
stopped so to say so let's go to more
game 5 so the first game of the clutch
game so Magnus plays h5 and going after
his opponent's king and here
LaVon missed opportunity to go at five
it's a route gauge it instead was played
King runs away so King runs to the other
side for safety and Magnus simply plays
on the King side so the king is very
safe on a3
and let's take a look at how he wins
this game takes and now the rook has the
open H file and the black rook cannot
fight for all open file Lucas Quinn goes
back doubling on the H file and just
penetrates taking a pawn and this
position is just completely hopeless
just the game ended here but g5 and the
game is over f6 is falling and b6 is
falling because white is simply going to
take every single pound on the board so
now Magnus has a four point lead so had
he won the next game - then six point
late is even with clutch games that are
worth three points each I would say in
the match is over it's very unlikely
that Magnus was going to lose the last
two games and maybe even a game between
that or they were gonna have four draws
and Magnus was gonna lose the last two
games so I think six points basically
will be match over but unfortunately for
level Magnus plays a huge blunder in the
last game so let's take a look so ice we
see black is up a lot of funds which of
course made the answer Sarah Vaughn who
notoriously likes to capture pawns very
happy and here he Magnus wonders with E
- which is such a natural looking move
because you know you attack a rule gives
him it's going to move and you're
threatening to take on f1 would it check
actually because of your promotes or not
it's going to be a check so your
opponent will have to react to it but
then LaVon has this amazing resource of
Quinn d1 attacking the rook and
threatening to get Quinn on his own so
instead of playing E - now that we see
this Queen d7 threat the Queen should
have just gone back and like is I've
just way too many pawns and should be
able to convert this position with all
these pawns
okay but let's go to the game so u2 is
played Queen d7 Queen sorry Knights with
a check
so it gives up the rock again but lemon
doesn't go for adventures by capturing
and simply goes for perpetual and we and
the and this match with four-point lead
for magnus carlsen so magnus was
actually quite happy about the level of
his play and the result of course and
Levon he felt like he couldn't do enough
to make Magnus uncomfortable and you
know to really cause any damage and as
she said tomorrow he has to go berserk
to try to stay alive but let's take a
look at our next match between Fabiano
Koren and Wesley so so since I already
told you that this match is mirrored
each other so you already know the
result of every single game but as I
said the result only tells half of the
story
so if you're familiar with the name zone
he goes fc5 he goes f3 which hasn't been
played before the computers hated
computers things this is just losing and
Fabiano himself called it kind of a
bluff but it still required for black to
find some very precise moves which
Wesley did so cause here sacrifice is in
exchange and Queen h5 Bishop d3 and f6
so this is all good so this was required
for like to find to get the edge in the
position and safe to say that the
experiment did not go as well as
expected but that's what happens when
you take a risk right sometimes things
go your way and sometimes they don't
so let's jump to a key moment in the
game because the way was the played this
game was just amazing so let's go to
this moment so Wesley goes f5 great move
with the idea of putting the bishop on
the long diagonal and starting the
attack of his own so doubling the rooks
just giving up that exchange on f6 and
just playing against his opponents King
to h5 threatening stake on g4 utilizing
this pin
tonight h5e five opening up the position
and now
key moment and they gave beautiful shot
by Wesley so taking on f3 and there's
this concept in terms of attacking on
the most offended square so here we see
the possibilities of discovery check so
it's impossible to take the Queen and
instead he takes with the king but after
check takes the bishop and it's
impossible to hold on to this position
so taking the knight is impossible the
rook takes back and it's a double attack
on the Queen and the rook really
beautiful final move attacking the rook
so here a Fabiano resigned the only move
would be Activa han which runs in
Chennai Jesus check which is a very
beautiful way to end the game so the
match starts 1:0 in favor of Wes Lisa so
what's this so with the white pieces so
this was a long grind and looked like it
was going to be a draw for a very long
time but some chances were found
so King G for his plate Leslie with the
light pieces so we see this King a
little bit uncomfortable so here Fabiana
misses this nice shot of playing bishop
by 4 if you take going for this endgame
it doesn't matter what the King goes and
he should be able to draw this and game
quite comfortably let's say here here
and the King will run in front of the
pawn instead in the game he plays Bishop
before and now we see that things start
to get a little uncomfortable for him
because White has a much better King
against the black King takes the c5 pawn
defense the pawn defense tonight and
this pawn starts rolling the King comes
back to support the pawn so there's a
lot of harmony in White's position
because they're all the pieces are
defending each other and here Wesley won
the
because Fabiana resigned here because it
just impossible to stop this fun and
this harmony of these pieces is just
amazing it's impossible to attack any of
them Knight and rook are on the light
square so the bishop cannot do anything
so this games were actually quite
peaceful and not a lot of action
happened so let's take a quick look
through them and we'll move on to our
clutch games because those were the
crucial ones so in this position
Fabiana rushes with h6 instead he should
try roti 6 and try to play this this
endgame he relies in his Bishop tried to
bring his King in using his passed pawn
and he goes h6 and they enter this route
and games I've already seen a lot of
return games in this tournament it's
kind of a theme so giving up this point
a very nice move because if the pawn
takes now we get to fast pawns on the
other opposite sides of the board which
becomes problematic for whites
eventually the king will go have to run
back and like we'll take this instead
Fabiano takes with the king and this is
quite an easy drum so there's a no draw
for before more 60 rules so just to end
the game he gives up a pawn to enter
King and King automatic draw and moving
on and let's take a look at our game 4
which is the final game before the
clutch games so this game was also
wasn't very adventurous West it was on
the better side of the Trump so here he
goes
f5 he could have tried with the rook a
for trying to take the pawn but because
there's a limited material on the board
still feels like black should make a
draw very easily because even once we
trade a pair of pair of pants you know
if you go f5 f6 I might I will just even
give up my bishop and just go
to ignite versus rook endgame and that's
a very easy drum so he goes at five
today isn't really much to say about
this games quite balanced game and we
want to save our time for the excitement
and drop by repetition alright and now
it's time for the clutch games so in the
first game Fabiana has the white pieces
and it looked like he was gonna make a
big comeback he played the Evans gambit
and as Wesley so noted and his postgame
interview that his opponent had a
different approach to this mash and in
the first money Fabiana was surprising
him more in the opening which is always
an unpleasant thing to face when your
opponent comes prepared and they're
blitzing out all the moves and you know
you're sitting there and you're trying
to figure out what to do and move like
five or six and or ten even and they're
just they just know everything so that's
kind of frustrating but clearly Wesley
was up to the challenge so I placed the
Evans gambit so if you look at this
position just looks completely lost like
let's look at this like what is this
King right but you know winning the one
position is not an easy thing to do
especially when your opponent doesn't
collapse and this is what the very top
players are very good at they don't
collapse they keep the game going and
the longer the game goes
it increases the likelihood of mistakes
for both sides so in this position
Fabiana plays Bishop d3 and the entrance
suggests and he also said this after the
game that he should have played we
should be v giving up the exchange and
putting the pawn on d5 and or even
checking this King chasing it away
actually even more accurate and then
taking this and just chasing this bishop
away putting the pawn on d5 utilizing
this diagonal and it's really hard for
block to defend this King because this
Knight it's not easy to move you don't
invite the Queen into the game like
there's equipment for example let's
let's ignore the fact that the rook is
hanging just to show you a point the
knight cannot move because
and now there are some problems in the
position so after the pan goes to d5 and
white gets control of the center opens
up this a1 AJ diagonal on the King this
position is going to be very tough to
defend
instead Bishop d3 was played which makes
a lot of sense right putting the bishop
on the same diagonal as the king
so Knight g5 the knight gets out so now
this should be fire but now it's a
little bit different because black
consolidated a little bit so he gives up
as a black keeps up the material but
manages to exchange a lot of pieces so
now more or less the worst is behind him
Atlas is not getting checkmated anymore
it's one of the principles when you're
getting attacked even exchange pieces so
takes a pawn comes back so white is
still pressing for the win but at some
point what goes wrong for him is he kind
of loses track of the game and this can
happen when you have a winning position
for a long time like the evaluation
changes but you don't really realize it
realize it because you think your
position is winning and you don't really
adjust to the changes in the position so
King runs away
Knight centralizes after he's hanging
it's a couple of repetitions and here is
the crucial mistake Fabiana goes after
the h4 pawn he should really grab the g4
pawn because check night f2 and now he
came to the very difficult realization
that after 21 Queen H 1 is just
unstoppable checkmate
so even though white was crushing to
this game yet this amazing attacking
position some moves later tables have
turned and now Wesley's the one with the
winning attack so queenie 195 just
ignores this the king is gonna run away
from the checks and this is impossible
to stop this checkmate and he had to
resign giving his opponent 4 point lead
so of course it's very difficult
psychologically difficult thing to deal
with because you know you have the white
pieces you
crushing your opponent you have this
just incredible attacking position like
all your pieces aren't underpass squares
and then everything goes wrong and
you're the one who gets made it so now
we have the final game services so the
white pieces of course he's a very solid
player if you want to keep things as
they are to make a dry can do it very
easily so Fabiano tried everything he
could but nothing worked so what I like
in this game is this move age 5 because
the pans are so weak so it was age five
asking his opponent how he's going to
react so he took with a knight of course
taking with the pawn is also possible
but then we can go after e and then take
this pawn and the c4 pawn is actually
going to be quite annoying so in certain
ith 5 was played and now we reach this
very equal position so Fabiana tries a
few things but BES it just goes back
defends everything just nothing because
the position just doesn't offer enough
so they just go back and forward a few
times they find some kind of repetition
in the game ends so great results both
for Magnus Carlsen
and what's the saw so they're leading by
4 points but as both of them or actually
for four of them mentioned the match is
not over because there's still six
clutch points to claim in the last two
games tomorrow and the first tie break
of the tournament our clutch points so
if the trailing player is Fabiano quran
and Levin are among the last two clutch
games and the match ends in a tie they
will actually win the match to advance
so there's still a lot to play for
tomorrow so I think there's there's
still a lot of life left in this match
you can watch the games life starting at
1:00 p.m. Central
with commentary but yeah so serve and
judge Harry and Maurice Ashley make sure
you check it out